let's talk about your resume my name is
Martin McGovern and I am a career
advisor here at Udacity and today we're
gonna be talking about the three biggest
mistakes that we all make when updating
our resume big mistake number one typos
it almost seems like it should go
without saying the typos are the number
one reason why people get screened
during the job search and it makes sense
when you spend that many hours building
a resume and staring at the same piece
of paper you tend to get a little bit of
blurry vision so what you want to do is
reach out to a friend or family member
and have a second set of eyes take a
look before you hit Send and send your
resume off to that dream job number two
length
now this one's hotly debated with a lot
of people saying a two-page resume is
okay but the truth the matter is is that
a recruiter is only going to spend about
6 seconds reading your resume so you
want to make sure that all the necessary
and most relevant information is easy
for them to consume if they're flipping
back and forth or dealing with staples
it's just going to be less effective
than if you got it all concisely on one
page and big mistake number three
customization now it makes sense we have
a lot of jobs that were probably
applying to during the job search but
you want to make sure that your resume
is customized for the role that you're
applying to and you're not just sending
a generic resume out there now how do
you customize you find a job description
that you really liked and you pull
keywords out and themes out and you make
sure everything in your resume is
tailored to match what these job
descriptions and these companies are
looking for so let's review number one
make sure there's no typos by having
someone give your resume a second look
number two be concise and get all your
information down to one page and number
three customize your resume to actually
fit what the companies are looking for
and that way you're going to stand out
and have the best chance of finding your
dream job thank you so much for watching
my name is Martin McGovern we're gonna
be bringing you a lot more videos like
this so if you have any other resume
questions or if you have tips of your
own please put them in the comments and
if you know anyone who's searching for a
job right now
tagging below them let them know you're
thinking about them good luck in your
search and we'll see you soon
[Music]